hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lam waifu and we're not
going to say any more than that as an
intro because we have a lot
to cover so deep breath
and let's go okay episode 131 i'm not
going to say this will be easy because
it won't as far as reviewing goes the
balance of the episode and the things
that happened and the thoughts i have
around it they're all complex
and they needed time to soak in and it
seems like that's a pretty consistent
experience so i guess
that's an episode with a job well done
going a layer deeper the colours of this
episode were strikingly beautiful and
the variation in tone and style were
consistently strong
something tagashi has done from the
beginning to now is use a change in art
style to indicate
a change in psychological functioning
and we very obviously got to see that
used to its fullest extent here
i don't have any ability to use
punctuation correctly so this is fun
so getting another level in on this on
this this thing here the setting was
perfect what looks like a monastery with
respectful people watching with
people and things we don't want to
destroy with silence and prayer and
intoned hymns and candles that we almost
snuffed a few episodes earlier we were
in a setting worthy of deities and
demons and that
was a wonderful choice in my episode of
130
i talked about external and internal
locus of control
the idea that outcomes could be assigned
either to someone else
or the self for the purposes of
reconciling an event
when gon first made the commitment to
rescue kite he blamed pito for the
situation
and the closer he got to that situation
the more he assigned blame
to pito until he was hardened and
pitiless toward anyone
including the young blind woman who had
nothing to do with anything
in 130 he began to struggle with the
idea that perhaps the blame was his
and near the end of that review i
suggested that gone would be unable to
resolve those two views in a balanced
and meaningful way because he's too
young it takes maturity to acknowledge
that neither or both those potentials
could be true simultaneously
i also suggested what he might do if he
were able to resolve that understanding
based on how gone has acted in the past
well
in 131 we're incredibly lucky because
gone gave himself the time
sort of and he managed to resolve it and
oddly he sort of resolved the situation
in exactly the way i hypothesized so
yay me i guess there's so much to cover
and honestly i'm not really sure where
to start so i'll just dive in with the
first thing that comes to mind and hope
it sort of leads to other things which
is
the idea of an avenging angel or a true
demon what i found fascinating about the
start of god's transformation was that
beyond the dark fire it started with the
same
imagery of strings that pito's ability
does at first i thought gon was being
controlled by something in the building
or that he was being loaned
strength by something in the building
the wind that blew out the candles the
men he gathered the growth the imagery
was of strings
of all the things pito has done in this
entire arc i think the biggest mistake
it made was not to tell gone it wouldn't
try to heal kite the silent breaking of
a promise
a truth that sat in front of a lie is
what pushed gone to the lengths he
reached
and all of it was predicated on a lie
and that's fascinating because i'm
trying really hard to find a time when
someone has lied to gone
not just being cruel or hurtful but
actually lied and please tell me if i'm
wrong but i can't think of a lie that's
been told
to him that he knew was a lie and not
only that but he hasn't told one either
he's all kinds of odd this kid but he
hasn't told a lie to my memory
in fact he's gone out of his way to make
sure that everyone knows what he
believes
it's entirely possible that that is the
reason we've been in his mind so little
why would we need to be in his head if
what he's doing is consistent with what
he's saying
and so sitting in what i'm calling a
monastery gone hears a lie and becomes
at first
what i'd call an avenging angel the
darkness and explosion of power that
comes
from him searching through the
information given and realizing that
actually he doesn't care about any of it
anymore
if it's so easy to deceive and so easy
to lose because someone decides not to
stick to the rules he's going to throw
everything away
you can't fix kite he doesn't actually
care about meruem in that situation at
all
because why would he care his only
reason for engaging in any of the events
of the ark was to reap revenge on pito
for hurting kite
to have kite restored neither of those
can happen so why
care he forgets that he's looking for
his father he forgets that he's trying
to learn why his father wanted to be a
hunter he forgets that there are
questions he has yet to answer
and now that i think about it now that i
say it maybe he doesn't he goes through
a process of growth and i'd be really
surprised if things didn't click
together in that moment for him
in that time maybe he realizes why his
father took kite under his wing maybe he
understood why kite had to kill to
protect him as a child and why
kite was angry about that basically i
keep flip-flopping between wondering
whether gone in the chaotic experience
of understanding deception and the true
potential of life for the first time
helped him realize that his father
became a hunter because there was no
other meaning
or reason to life or if there was
something else
and and he didn't have that experience
at all his father's existence gave him
meaning
first the meaning was understand me that
is something to work towards that's
something to live for
understand me and then it became well
you somewhat understand
now come find me finding kite was
potentially more powerful than any of
that because that was physical
more physical than his father's ever
been but also kite explained that the
purpose of finding jing was to find
meaning
maybe jing was just a metaphor for
existence and that's not
enough kite's the only one to whom gon
has ever been loyal
he searched for his father but he's
never given himself over to someone
that was kite we saw a few episodes ago
what happened when poof and yupi thought
marowan was dead
now we see the counter to it here
loyalty is a marvelously positive and
powerful trait
until it's cut from its source on pito's
end i found it interesting that they
were sad
to kill him he'd been a respectable
combatant to now
and they recognize why gone had to do
what he did when they remember who he
was
and why he'd track them down but they
have to follow their gut and their
loyalty and protect the king if there's
anything this episode did
it was bring together three incredibly
powerfully
loyal individuals and turn them on each
other pito's fear of the avenging angel
pushed it to do exactly what it needed
to do give itself
over to the power it wielded that it
never fully understood because we can't
forget that the ants aren't finished
evolving
they've been developing mentally and
physically since the beginning of the
arc and it is important very important
to be very aware of the extent to which
they have evolved
in such a short time as well as the fact
that they're not finished evolving yet
and so when pito tells its power to take
control of it it puts every
ounce of its loyalty into that ability
that there to me is the end of pito that
moment is pito's last line for me
go beyond that is pito's last line it's
not pito's last line overall i'm aware
but it's the last moment pito is in
charge of itself
even though it may have been under
perf's spell the decision on how to use
its ability and the level of
significance it held takes the award
here's an award pito
congratulations the most willing to do
anything in aid of another
pito has been seen to have red eyes in
fear for the king before more
specifically though its eyes were red in
anger despite being in a situation where
they were thrown far from mary when they
were thrown they didn't believe the king
could actually be killed by the
situation it was an inconvenience and it
was the anger of a soldier
a lieutenant the guard when pito's eyes
go golden in this episode i associate
that with purity
with loyalty with love pito's giving of
itself
is in body and in soul and while the
outcome is horrific
it proves how pure pito's love is for
its king
which is somewhat unlike the other two
guards who give of
themselves but not to this extent what
we see through the episode i suppose is
a slow reversal of roles
gone goes from demon to angel while pito
goes from angel
to demon ultimately there is no blame to
a sign
kite died and so they have both gone
beyond
burning up their souls for the thing
they believe in and gone
gone grew up he went full super saiyan
he grew his hair
really long and wavy and it like does
its own thing like his hair
he's got nanny hair mandy nenny's hair
he got himself some serious musculature
and he seems to have gained some
maturity the stretchy sky hair of our
age with the powerful maturity to accept
it and accompany it the cute kid's gone
well the cute kid has got the cute the
cute kid has left as kilowatt noticed
it was the reverse of biscuit enhancer
has enhanced
in every way and pito's last thought was
of the fact that there was no way it
could go further
the hatred gone felt for it would burn
out like a sun how many years he had
burned up already in the space of a
moment it doesn't matter that gone is as
powerful as the king now it doesn't
matter that he could be the most
powerful creature on the planet
he wouldn't use it effectively and that
for pito was soothing
not for killa though killer's had a hard
day
the person he cares about most dismissed
him severally he's had a cry
about it stopped a butterfly from
killing an ungrateful hostage and
arrives just in time to see that any
chance he had with gone is now going to
be seriously awkward because of the
decades of age difference between them
oh and his friend decides to go
supernova after stabbing a corpse with
his own dismembered
arm poor kid the changes in art style
took us through the last moments of life
before that supernova moment and i just
i just feel bad for my poor boy you know
cause god warned him back in the game
that anything to do with his dad was a
priority over kilauea's existence and
he's happy to prove it
well i mean maybe not happy but he's
proved it many times
and this moment sort of points out that
kite was more of a dad than his
dad given the lengths he's gone to i was
genuinely afraid that in all of
that all of the emotions all of the big
things that happened
at the end of this episode that kilwa
would give his life to stop gone from
being hit
by terpsakora and on reflection i
actually think i'd have preferred it if
that had happened if keowa dies now he
knows he died because gone cared more
about something else than him
rather than dying knowing he gave his
life for something he believed in
i don't know i think i'd prefer that
dying with his friend essentially saying
he had no reason to live anymore and
taking him along for the ride that's not
i mean that's just not cricket
beyond which it's sad that gon says he's
finished the job the way kite taught him
to
kite didn't want to kill anyone or
anything but told gone that in order to
save people he had to do a horrific
thing who has gone saving by killing
pito
does he even remember there are more
episodes and only one person who could
see the situation as it exists now so i
can only assume or hope that more will
happen in this location
and that my boy my little murder boy
well
the little murder boy and his man crush
will survive
i can't say there are many people who
have punched someone using their own
dismembered arms so that gets
to go into the hall of fame for most
absurd combat moves gone and pito made
their choices
pitot to protect its king gone to punish
them both for the death of the only
person he was loyal to
which was in fact the thing that i
predicted
would happen if he could gain that level
of maturity
after allowing kite's body to punch him
all those episodes ago he finally
got to experience the punishment he
thought he deserved huwa also made
his choice and his was the most
pacifistic choice of them
and i do wonder what kilauea would do if
gone were gone
while he has powerful emotions too i
think oddly he expresses
them more healthily than gon does and so
i doubt he'd use his rage to become an
avenging alien
alien i doubt he'd use his rage to
become an avenging angel
or a ghostly storm and destroy
everything because gone is dead
if the story continues as it should pito
and gone should
by rights both die that said the series
continues and they've managed to get out
of it in very strange ways so
we'll see soon but not now because
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this long delve into a
single episode hit like
share and subscribe take a nap and i'll
see you
next time